yeah welcome to this video and a playing
I'm pretty well-known Grandmaster NICTA
fermion this is a really a rag s than
five minutes yes I don't think I have
played him let's briefly check this he
played a couple of five-minute games but
I never played I mean this is curious
okay so we have a reuleaux pass the
tried and tested mainline and he's for
some reason not playing c3 you know he
does okay and I'm playing my cheat
already my main advantage is some this
kind of line that I have played it so
often I'm sorry and I played it so often
that I'm really young have some idea
what to do okay so it's a bit different
he played them slightly unusual move
order became so I'll just allow this
transposition I have fun rather
complicated looking plan in mind a five
is a five not be fibers estrangement
okay now play before if he goes c4 I
just pick up the pawn this pawn is a
potential weakness
yeah grandma said he found me and he am
a longtime veteran GM C intend to is
giving me c3 but maybe he wants to take
Knight F takes e5 interesting
interesting idea I don't know good young
at f65 this could be an idea take Cindy
6 mm yeah we'd I'm not sure if this
really is such a problem again all this
is slightly weird let's see what happens
I'm just trying to pick up the pawn I
will I will manage but it's not clear
that it leads to such a great position
yeah I can take take a five he will play
em reveal he cannot play in the rook at
the moment okay he can take with the
rook actually not with the pawn just was
stupid yeah I simply forgot that you can
take with the rook and this also should
lead to a good position for white yeah
this was silly
yeah I just forgot about that okay
yes it's just anticipates before yeah
yeah very silly okay but it's still a
very a very closed position of some I'm
not necessarily a in terrible shape
between d8 was intending this to
exchange of this bishop
yeah 93 prevented that I can unite h5 -
for at least them get this into the mix
yeah intending age four he has to play H
for himself now now maybe night night
somewhere but he aged for something that
he would like to prevent I guess
yeah I'm not in such a bad shape here I
completely miss played this on the
queenside but somehow it's not
yeah well h4 was was simple and good
this is just it's strange why would you
allow that this just gives me a good
position
yeah I know sometimes you come across
some very strong players on on paper and
he's rated like two five something in in
regular time controls but somehow they
have completely different ideas about
chess than you have it sometimes just
happens with them this guy he regularly
does um yeah um works as a commentator
for ICC for for grandmaster tournaments
and I never really get what he's saying
for some reason it seems that we have
completely opposite ideas about about
the game yeah it didn't understand any
of this okay but he I'm just saying that
he's closing up the King said I should
have taken on g1 g3 before would have
been much better now the Sun position is
rather closed and Asics of course his
son is hanging
yeah yeah it's so stupid okay I can
still try to get them some play him
advancing pieces towards the king but
them objectively this is not great at
all who came you know this night I saw a
very sad piece
yeah difficult to to get any any sort of
counterplay him Queen f6 is a six now
it's just bad
yeah white is white is just just clearly
better there's more than one way to play
just trying to to activate and dislodge
some pieces from the King don't have any
any concrete @dm and fortunately
this could have been could have been
even worse I guess it's still very bad
but time morning table I just blend up
the Queen what oh my god
yeah okay black resigned oops
yeah it's um it's probably lost anyway
nobody should be five that's just the
draw
yeah this is just yeah very obviously
you get this and you know I don't have
any problems of mine yeah I probably
would have won this it's just much more
comfortable for black okay but of course
I was I was just coach was dead before
he just needs to take or Queen c7 TM
Queen c7 wins yeah I completely screwed
up on the King sir on the Queen side
first and then I forgot to take on g3 I
simply here I need to take here first
and then then this one this isn't
completely clear white is better but I
have some I have some play like this he
needs to be needs to be cautious cannot
play like any move and win but okay I
have I had really completely forgotten
that after the captions he formed him
here here that's not so much going on
really and if I just forgot that he can
take with the rook Bishop c4 is just
stupid
and I thought you would take here and
after the capture he will get the a6
pawn but it's not it's not so terrible
so this was some getting me into trouble
yeah the problem is at one point he will
play b4 and get a six this is just just
quite uncomfortable yeah I didn't
understand at all why it isn't playing H
for himself this is just the normal move
keeping keeping a big edge but he
somehow didn't do that and allowing edge
four is just just a mistake okay and
yeah I just forgot to take on g3 after
this it's just too slow we will get a
six and I have no cover to play
whatsoever all right
thanks for watching